oh boy oh geez word Smiths I'm not
feeling so hot about this word I tell
you what the word is
anxious anxious or if you prefer
anxious it's an adjective that means
very worried you might seen in its noun
form
anxiety which is the state of being very
worried if you trace this word back to
its Origins you get the Latin word Ang
which means to choke or to squeeze when
I feel anxious sometimes my throat gets
tight and my heart hammers in my chest
and listen wordsmiths it's a bad time
and that o Us Part US is an adjective
forming suffix it means full of right so
being anxious is being full of that
choking squeezed feeling so a real fun
one this time huh let's all take a deep
breath think of a calming centered place
and come up with some related words some
similar words that sound like angare or
ous that end in ous I'll put on some
calming
music 10 seconds here we
go here are three that I came up with
we've got anguish it shares the same
root as anxious that Ang word and it
means misery torment very deep
unhappiness as if you were being choked
or squeezed
Agony okay uh next word anger this is an
interesting one because anger looks a
lot like angare but actually traces back
to Old Viking languages not Latin but it
comes from an even older shared root a
common ancestor of Latin and the Viking
languages so it has the same meaning
squeezed or painful and from there we
get anger hostility feeling constricted
and squeezed and finally Furious using
that ous ending it means full of Fury
full of
anger I promise I'm having a very normal
day wordsmiths there's just something
about this derivation that puts me on
edge okay let's use anxious in a
sentence or two at first Betina felt
anxious about hiking needle teeth Gorge
but felt reassured when she remembered
that her Aunt Isabella was a trained
Wilderness guide needle teeth Gorge does
not sound like a fun or safe place to go
for a hike uh to me betina's worries are
understandable let's try another one
using the noun form of the word
anxiety based on what you told me it
seems like potatoes are the cause of
your anxiety Dr Gomez
said sometimes it helps to talk to
someone about your feelings potato
related or no deep breaths wordsmiths
you can do this you can conquer your
anxiety and you can learn
anything David out